well today I'm going to talk about
tensor decomposition part one and today
I'll focus on non symmetric tensors and
on part two and Friday I'll talk about
symmetric tensors you have notes
together with the homework assignment
and I will give you updated notes before
the Friday lecture ok well so what is a
tensor so McCullough's book on tensor
methods and statistics gives maybe like
ten definitions of what a tensor is I'll
just give you two today and what a
tensor is and maybe you have your own
favorite craft Commission so a tensor
well it's just a collection in of
numbers in a field so so F is going to
be the field and then a tensor is just
going to be a multi-dimensional array of
numbers that's that's our first
definition of a tensor well you may like
to have a slightly more abstract view of
a tensor so a tensor is going to be an
element and attempts are product of
vector spaces and I'll tell what this
says in a second
so a B and C are vector spaces over the
field and we'll call an element of the
tensor space a tensor so sort of a
circular definition but this vector
space with has a basis well I need to
declare the basis of my other vector
spaces first so these are going to have
basis a one day um B 1 to the N and C 1
C P basis
so then this tensor product space has
basis AI conserved Vijay sir CK okay so
it's a big vector space and I've
declared the basis for you this means
that I can write my tensor T as a linear
combination of the elements in the basis
okay so two different views in the
pension sensor is just a collection of
numbers in a multi-dimensional array or
it's an element of a tensor product
space okay so I want to stick with this
abstract approach for just a little bit
longer so let's talk about this tensor
symbol so I can define this simple
tensor as a map and again it seems a
little bit circular as written but I
hope that it'll be clear as I as we go
along so to find this map tensor product
just to take an element in X at element
and a and then element and B and map it
to this element X tensor Y and declare a
couple properties so we're going to
declare that this product is f by linear
that means that well let's do this is
number one and then number two tensor
product is associative okay so number
one just to recall what this means this
means that if I take lambda X plus X
prime and I tensor that with why this
distributes so this is X lambda times X
sensor y plus X prime tensor Y and then
similarly on the other side
okay so this is one this is for all X
and X Prime and a for all y and y Prime
and B and for all lambda in the field so
for us the field will usually be real or
complex numbers but if you like to study
a different field that's fine so I have
an F by linear map that I'm calling
tensor product and it's also associative
so to just means that if I tensor a
tensor B and then tensor see later
that's the same thing as if I tensor
first be in C together or I'm not going
to write it I could attend sir to a and
C together first and then add a B so
this means that this a tensor be tensor
C makes sense it makes sense to write
the triple tensor product that viewin
are only defined it for two factors okay
so the outline for the lecture today is
tensor basics these are a couple of the
tensor basics if you are interested in
some references I recommend a new book
of professor Landsberg there's also an
article is just published recently by
carlini grave and I saw four lectures on
secant varieties you have archived
identifiers here and then for the second
lecture have a reference of myself and
the two Vianney eigenvectors of tensor
and wearing decomposition so those those
references are in your notes so erase
them so now that everyone's here and
seated it's 9:00 in the morning then
10:00 in the morning I want to give you
an idea of what is tensor decomposition
by audience participation so what we're
going to do is if your birthday is in
September
like mine then I want you to you're
going to say in a moment the word tensor
if your birthday is not in the month of
September then I want you to pick a
random two syllable word and that's what
you're going to say we're all going to
say our word at the same time when I say
three and then I'm going to try to
how many people said ten sir all right
okay so you got the you got the idea if
your birthday's not in September say
random two syllable word if your
birthday is in September say ten sir
okay so on account of three on three say
your work okay one two three okay I
think seven people said ten sir I'm just
guessing I don't know if really certain
people said tenser so that's actually
really hard to do right I mean if you
were gonna in an audience if you're at a
restaurant and somebody says tensor well
I like tensor so I probably look when I
heard it out of the all the noise of all
the other things so let's try one more
time what we're gonna do on Friday is
something similar to the next exercise
we're going to add in redundancy to see
if we can actually find out who said
tensor and how many people said tensor
okay so now I want you to say your word
four times in a row okay so I'm three
say your word four times ago
one two great so I think maybe eight
people said it Thanks
I'm just guessing there's 70 people in
the room maybe seven areas people
birthday's on September so that's the
idea so there's lots of noise we want to
find the rank one tensors which are the
single people who said tensor out of all
the noise out of all the other things
that were said so that's the idea so
given T in a tensor be tensor see find
an expression
T is equal to a linear combination so
sound waves add as you as they all
arrived to my ears so this is going to
be a linear combination of s equals 1 to
our X of s sincere applies of us tensor
Z sub s and then X are an a the Y's are
d and the Z's are in the C okay so find
an expression this means find the
minimal R R is called the rank and then
this expression is called a
decomposition okay so in this
decomposition we're looking for that
vectors x y&z such that when we take
their tensor product right out that
expression in Basie's add up all of the
expressions we get a single tensor and
we want to recover these individual
summons we're gonna find the rank R and
so on so we covered tensor basics maybe
you think this problem is easy so I
recommend looking at a paper of LEM and
Hitler the title is really easy to cite
it's called most tensor problems are NP
hard
so if you're wondering maybe why this is
an interesting problem most problems in
linear algebra are polynomial time
solvable maybe matrix multiplication so
on to something interesting the tensor
problems are usually empty hard so this
problem that I wrote here just count the
number of variables and the number of
equations that are involved in this
expression and you'll find that this is
a really hard system of polynomial
equations to solve as john mentioned
yesterday but nonetheless it's constant
time solvable when we fix our vector
spaces ABC and our rank R so why should
we be afraid of np-hard it's constant
time solvable so one goal of this
lecture and the next lecture is to solve
the smallest problems that we can solve
for tensor decomposition and not try to
find a general necessarily algorithm to
solve all problems we would solve P
versus NP we're not trying to do that in
these lectures but we are trying to
solve the smallest cases but we need to
sort of set algebraic geometry framework
for these problems it'll make it easier
to study them so since we're talking
sort of an abstract this a little bit
about sensors let's do one more one more
basic thing and now I will erase the
outline okay so some vector spaces
finite dimensional vector spaces come
with their natural basis that we've
chosen so we can define a dual vector
space
so a star is just the linear maps and
approved for fritter at an alpha
there's a ground field and then we have
dual basis alpha 1 to alpha M and we
have the duality is alpha I of a J is
just the Kronecker Delta function don't
picture so dual basis dual vector spaces
so why do I need this so I want to talk
about tensors from the point of view of
matrices go back to some familiar in
familiar ground ok so we could think
about a matrix first and this sort of
slightly more abstract view so I'm going
to think about the vector space a tensor
P and then let's take an inside of a
tensor P well this represents a linear
map
well actually represents to naturally
new maps so we're going to that one of
them first so let's write it a map from
a sorry to be so how do I get a linear
map out of my matrix so out of my
element and in tensor space so it's
going to be a sum I J scalars m IJ the
audience in Syria BJ so this is my
abstract tensor but I'm going to write
it as a matrix by doing what I do in
freshman linear algebra so I want to
understand the linear map then I
evaluate it on the basis and I put the
results in the columns of my matrix I
hope that we all remember this so so
what is it going to do this my mouth
we'll still call it M so M takes an
element alpha I and maps it to well the
sum over I well let's make this an S so
it looks different somewhere for I so
we're j mi J and then the alpha s eats a
I and multiplies by BJ so this is what
this does and so now my matrix in the S
column is going to have well this
expression simplifies a little bit
because the Kronecker Delta function
this is just the sum now over J equals 1
to n m s j bj so i'm trying to be
careful with indices so this is maybe
counterintuitive what goes in the X
column s J so the row index X is
indexing actually the columns for this
matrix so this is the transpose of what
you expect
well the transpose went up of what I
might have expected
okay but I shouldn't have chosen
necessarily a to be my favorite vector
space maybe B was my favorite vector
space so let's write the other linear
rap I'm still going to call it M from V
star to a and do exactly the same thing
beta sub s is going to go to the sum now
let me shorten this is going to be an i
from 1 to M I pass by so betas are dual
basis so then this is the matrix whose s
column is M is this is the usual matrix
that we would associated with these
indices so this is clear how to take an
abstract vector in a tensor product
space and write it as a matrix great so
we're going to do the same thing now for
a tensor we're going to use the fact
that the tensor product is associative
to define the notion of a flattening so
recall that I said okay a tensor be
tensor C makes sense but I'm going to
write this as a tensor be censored with
C so there's one more thing I want to do
before this I forgot so we're going to
vectorize borrowing from applied
language vectorize my matrix M so I'm
going to write M the notation will be
more clear in a moment M lower C is
going to be the vector after a chosen
well M this is M lower seed now it's
going to be a linear map from a tensor B
could have done the other thing go down
to my field I'm still calling my field F
so let's call this out okay so I could
have put all the vector spaces on the
left hand side of the
and not just to the ground field so what
this should be is a very long bacteria
and then one row right okay so this is
going to be M 1 1 M 1 to M 1 n bar the
bars are just spacers and then M 2 1 & 2
2 2 and down to M M 1 to M okay so we
can vectorize matrices so we can
actually maître size tensors and that's
what we're about to do here we're going
to maître size and I don't really like
this word so I'm going to call it
flattening
okay so Maitre size is taking a tensor
and making it into a matrix but I'm
actually going to call it a flattening
so we're gonna write T sub C as a linear
map now looking at this space of vector
this exactly the same way as we thought
of a matrix is a linear map like this
so I ignore the extra structure I need
tensor B think of it as a vector space
and now I can write a matrix by the same
process that I did before and just so I
don't mess up the indices let me write
them so we're thinking of our tensor as
the sum over K sum over J sum over I g
IJ K a tensor of BJ and then I'm gonna
parenthesize here a tensor okay so this
is the abstract thought of the
flattening and now I write those right
of s and matrix
so remember tensors and for now I mean
all of the properties we want to study
are and capture captured by a triple
tensor product so I'm still going to
focus on three factors well three
indices so the first n tracks
entry in my matrix is T 1 1 1 and then
I'm flattening every matrix that I see
give me one second director so it's a
little bit long but it's also in the
notes
okay the first row of my flattening
looks like this so what stayed constant
in the first row is the last index
alright the second row looks like this
to do 1 1 2 2 1 2 2 2 1 and 2 2 on 1 2
that's what the second row looks like
and so on all the way down to the last
entry okay so the flattening of the
tensor is equivalent information of the
tensor but we're choosing to write it as
a matrix these blocks that I've
indicated here are called the slices of
a tensor maybe I'll index this by okay
so the first slice what's constant in
this matrix is the first entry its t1
and then I leave the next two entries
blank this is t2 blank blank and then
this is T M blank blank those are the
names of my slices in this direction
okay so does everybody know how to take
a three-dimensional tensor and flatten
it if you imagine your rubik's cube as
being here three by three by three
tensor you're going to pick an
orientation and cut it straight down
like slices of bread and then lay them
out next to each other that's what the
flattening is okay so of course I can do
this for all choices just like it did
matrices going to two different vector
spaces I also can define and I'm not
gonna write them but TV is going to be a
map from a tensor C dual to be T C is
going to be a map for me
you'll see where you get this one and
then ta is a map from B to C - hey okay
so I have three flattening for a
three-dimensional tensor and I have many
more flattening for a multi-dimensional
more dimensional tensor and well I chose
Basie's to write all of these things but
the the expressions that I came up with
what's invariance about what I did here
is that the the matrices themselves with
the ranks so I'm going to collect the
ranks into what's going to be called the
multi linear rank
the MRT is equal to the rank of ta Frank
GP Thank You C okay so one thing that
you hope that you hopefully remember
from linear algebra is that matrices
have many definitions of rank that all
agree right so the row rank equals the
column rank equals the number of rank
one summons need to express it equals
the SVD rank equals the number of nonlin
nonzero eigen values kind of
multiplicity there's so many definitions
of rank four matrices which are great
this is the first definition of rank
'wish the row rank call the rankin into
the board rank don't agree so let's see
an example sorry to do so much notation
first and then the example second but so
here's my example the smallest possible
example I could come up with where the
multi-layer ranks are not all the same
so let's take my tensor is a 1 tensor
you want to see one okay so maybe you
can see immediately what the multilinear
ranks are but let's just write down the
flattening send them over here it's just
just so we're all on the same page so TC
GV da okay so what's this flattening so
I'm in a very pedantically number the
columns just so we're really clear on
what this matrix is so the rows are
indexed by a tensor see elements are
agents of B and the columns are indexed
by elements in C right so wherever I see
ok 1 1 1 this means a1 b1 c1 I put a 1
here put the coefficient of that term
here and then there's only one other
term and it's indexes here ok and all
the rest of entries are 0 so that's a
flattening in the C direction TP well T
and V are symmetric so these two are
going to be the same but now I'm going
to index DB by entries a tensor C and
then the columns might be and this
matrix looks like this and then da is
the same matrix ok ok so now we can
compute the multi linear rank of this
tensor let's see 2 2 & 1 okay so the
multi linear ranks are not all the same
why do I start with multi linear rank
instead of tensor rank so I think that
this is perhaps the biggest dimensional
reduction that you can make when you're
first answering any question about a
tensor so if somebody gives you a
million by million by million tensor
then you're going to have a tensor with
more entries than the federal debt but
then you might say well do I really need
that many entries in my tensor ok so
here's an example let's let's take
another example let's suppose I just add
up all the first basis vectors and then
add up all the first basis vectors in
the next factor maybe it seems
artificial to do this but let's see what
we get
so this is my next example this is the
all one sensor
so it's certainly not sparse and it's
completely filled with nonzero entries
but it's actually just lives in a one
dimensional space so T actually lives in
a copy of C 1 or F 1 okay so versus T
which is just a one dimensional vector
space versus T inside of C M&P which is
possibly very large okay so this is a
large dimensional
reduction
okay so if you're trying to solve a
system of linear system of polynomial
equations for a tensor problem you
should probably first reduce the number
of variables so that you don't have to
deal with the huge number of variables
in the first place of it it's possible
to move your tensor into a space which
has less variables you're going to save
time and do your computation
okay so this brings me to this this
conference is about minute algebraic
geometry and complexity theory so what's
the algebraic variety involved here is
called the subspace variety so the
subspace variety have just shown you a
few instances of it so let's just okay
so the subspace variety even next by RS
and T is equal to well it's going to be
the lines through tensors and PDA
Pinsir the tensor just me so rank isn't
unchanged by scalar multiples so I might
as well work through work with lines
through the origin
okay so so this is going to be I need
there to be a subspace in each direction
and he actually lives in the tensor
product of the subspaces and the
dimensions a prime is our dimension B
prime is s and dimension C prime 50 okay
sort of a long definition but it's the
variety of tensors which can be written
using fewer tensor variables possibly
fewer rft instead of n n P okay so this
subspace variety if you want to test
whether your tensor lives in the
subspace variety how can you test this
so we should find the defining equations
of this algebraic variety this is a test
so proposition perhaps part of this is
classical but let me let me attribute
the there's a more refined statement
but what I'm going to say is probably
classical classical there's some more
refined statement due to Landsberg in
women is that the ideal well the ideal
is defined by the equation that's the
questions that you expect how can I test
whether my tensor has multi linear rank
rst this is equal to the tensors you
know in another definition it's the same
definition such that the multi linear
rank of T is less than or equal to rst
okay so how can I test multi linear rank
well I tested to a similar test rank
four matrices with by minors so the
ideal actually is generated by the R
plus 1 by r plus 1 minors flattening to
the a direction so T a and then the S
plus 1 by s plus 1 minors of T P and T
plus 1 by T plus 1 minors of T C ok I
want to do one more thing with this
tensor here what's the image well the
image of T C is just the linear span of
C 1 the image of T V is V 1 and C 1 V 1
and V 2 sorry and then the image of T a
is a 1 and a 2 so I didn't say where the
sense I live in the beginning it could
have lived in a huge space but it
actually lives in this the span of a 1
and a 2 tensor with this
you want to you too you could have seen
this from the expression but maybe if
somebody else gave this tensor in a
slightly different set of coordinates it
wasn't so obvious that this was the case
okay so that's multi linear rank in the
subspace variety and the equations that
define the subspace variety you're gonna
test multi linear rank you test matrix
rank for the flattening x' okay so one
other fact about subspace varieties is
that they contain the tensors of small
rank well let me define the algebraic
variety first and I'll say make the
statement of containment in terms of
elevators that's right so so I can erase
this and the pen sir maybe five here
this is very general okay also this idea
that this variety is very nice as normal
rational singularities and it's
resolution is given by the women Kemp do
synchronization so there's a lot about
this variety that we know okay and then
of course you know appropriate size
flatness for all the other ones okay so
the next outbreak writing that we're
going to consider is called the second
variety
end after a classical Italian geometers
who study these things over 100 years
ago so I'm going to take the the
secretary product the product of 3d
projective spaces to the tensor product
of all of them which is going to take an
element X an element Y an element Z to
the class of a tensor product okay so
the sacred product is the image of this
map we'll just do it it's a gray sea and
it's equal to also the tensor is that
have Rank 1
this is a nice variety it's smooth it's
closed it's homogenius 4gl they cross
GTL
the cross GL see and it has some many
other nice properties so this is the the
variety of algebraic variety of rank one
tensors up to scale the next variety we
need it is called the secant variety
okay so remember a tensor has rank R
it's the sum of our rank one time series
so we might think about the algebraic
variety across it the tensors
so first of all isn't this an algebraic
variety it's not actually an algebraic
variety unless we take this a risky
closure
okay stay so this is Sigma our pink cups
okay so this is the the secant variety
of the segregate product and more
generally you can define the secant
variety if you have any X inside of
projective space algebraic variety Sigma
R of X is just equal to the class of
points in the n such that there exists X
1 X are the points and X such that P is
equal to X 1 plus XR that's the secant
variety the given variety
okay so in the homework there's a couple
of exercises I think to to show why this
variety is not close example tensor wish
okay so we say that these these guys
these tensors
define Commission reporter rank so it's
a little bit it's a little bit odd the
tensor is on the border don't have rank
are it's kind of opposite of what you'd
expect so-called border rank the all the
tensors who up to limit these are ski
sense or even a Euclidean sense have
rank line so most tensors they expect in
this space would have their garbage and
some of them could have different things
other than are okay so the next thing I
want to talk about is what to expect
about ranks so if somebody hands you a
tensor in a given space you should be
able to tell them what the rank probably
is but give you a random tensor and see
ten tensor see ten ten thirty ten what
should you tell them the rank is if it's
just random well let's figure this out
okay Rini is on the grape variety
algebraic geometry to determine what to
expect so what we need is so we don't
know about the expected ring
so and why do we want to do this is
because well the most naive way to solve
the tensor decomposition problem is to
guess a rank and then try to solve an
optimization problem define to you but
by the tensor decomposition equation so
try to solve so try to guess first R and
solve
or maybe optimized for some of your
favorite norm
okay so both of these problems are
extremely difficult but if you can guess
with the rankest first you might have an
easier time at finding the the solution
so so how do we guess the right the
right ring so one thing we should do
first of all is we should figure out
which subspace variety we're going to
work in and then we're going to after
that determine the determine which rank
we should expect but let's do
so yes if you sold this problem that
doesn't tell you that this are it only
tells you that there is it so you can
keep going back if you get really lucky
and solve a really hard problem and try
to solve a slightly easier a problem
with less variables and keep going down
usually the student may be of guests are
as small and go up where you could start
with biggest star possible if it
happened either way but try to guess the
right rank in this all okay so what
should you expect so well let's suppose
we have an algebraic variety here in PN
which is linearly non degenerate so it's
not inside of PN minus 1 then well the
first SECAM variety of the secant points
are just x contained in the second
second variety
and then up to some K which is going to
be equal to PN
so if you keep taking higher and higher
secant varieties and a given variety as
long as it's linearly non-degenerate
then it's going to eventually fill the
ambient space where it lives so the last
K for which we can we can find a
non-trivial inclusion we're going to
call that the expected rank so when X is
equal to the cigarette call this K the
expected rank or the tensor C okay so
over see there's one expected rank but
over R for instance if you interested in
that question that can be many so
they're called typical ranks
but over see this only one
so a typical rank is is a set is a rank
on which there's a set of positive
volume for which all the tensors in that
set have that same rank so even to my
two by two tensors over reals can have
two typical rings two and three okay so
now we just need to figure out when does
the secant variety fill its andean space
and then we'll know what to expect for
the rank
yes if you if you choose the entries of
your matrix randomly then you will
expect the expected rank four because
the previous the previous ones have
smaller dimension so they have measure
zero in any probability measure that you
put on the space okay he was asking what
distribution you choose the
I don't think it matters that's the
point
pick any distribution you want and for
that distribution the the tensors of
smaller erratic have measure zero we
just handed up line what won't one this
one that's gonna meet any open set once
at the selection meeting open sentence
you to five people pipe over something
- subspace sucking all the people would
not work I say be a little bit careful I
want to use the distribution where I
work through the secant variety an
impairment parameterless points on this
space by by writing actually the sama
group of K points sorry I don't work
with the probability distribution
function I can't believe something okay
so what when does K witness okay
okay so in order to determine this we're
going to determine this by computing
dimensions so I prefer the differential
geometry approach to dimension which is
a dimension in the tangent space
so first let's compute the dimension
Sigma 1 of X which is just the same so
what we're going to do is we're going to
pick a general well the cigarette
variety is homogeneous so every point on
its general picked a general point P
which is going to be for our purposes X
sensory replied Z ok so pick a terminal
point here and we're going to compute
the tangent space at X which is going to
be an affine space or subtract one for
the projective dimension or how do we
compute the tangent space so
let's do it in the example of the triple
second cigarette product so we're going
to pick a curve
okay so we pick a curve like this that's
on the cigarette product and the
definition of attendance businesses all
tangent directions - at this point so I
have a curve and I'm going to take the
collection of the tangent reactions at 0
4 for these curves so what I mean is
that I want X of 0 to be equal to x + y
0 to the y + Z of 0 to the Z and while
I'm at it let me tell you what the
derivatives are going to be just to an X
prime Y prime Z prime ok so pick a curve
like this so then the span of all of the
tangent directions of a curve through my
point on my cigarette product is just
going to be well gamma Prime at 0 is
equal to X prime concern Y concern Z
plus X Y prime tensor is Z plus X Y ok
so if you work through the product rule
for derivative some works over the
tensor products so this is what a
general tension vector looks like and we
take the all of them
looks like this well I could pick
anything in the first direction ten
served with my quite wide tensor with my
Quincy and then anything in the second
Direction X tensor the tensor c plus X Y
tensor C and relationship with the
linear span of XY and Z but the tensor
product is leaner so okay so now I would
be tempted to write direct sum but these
vector spaces are not disjoint not not
disjoint so actually I should write this
as X tensor license or Z this occurs in
all of them and then take a pond X
consider why consider C Drive some of
the texts why
okay so now I know the dimension of the
serger product it's the sum of these
dimensions
okay so that's the dimension of a
cigarette this should be what exactly
what you expected it's just the surfaces
okay so this means that they expected
well let me do one more proposition
which is the most useful tool and all of
that so listen carefully
called Tarek genius lemma so that's how
I compute the dimension of the tangent
space well compute the tangent space of
a cigarette product what about the
tangent space at some point of this
secant variety of X so turn teenie
teenies long as the most useful tool
determining reactor dimensions of secant
varieties and it's essentially just the
sum rule for taking the derivative so
Terry genius lemma says the following
that a teeny
in Sigma R of X general and X 1 to XR in
X also general
and he is the song then the tangent
space to my point of the secant tendon
space of the secant variety at my point
P is just the sum of the tangent spaces
this should be exactly what you're
expected because the points on this
variety are just some so we take the
derivative I take tangent vectors
something we get the solid so in maybe
this is best seen by by an example so
let's computer let's find out about two
by two by two tensors
okay so this is a Sigma 2 P 1 Cross P 1
plus P 1 so this is inside of seven
okay so first of all there aren't
tensors of rank to predict one tensors
don't fill up the whole space right
because there ain't one tensors are just
three dimensional when I'm inside of t7
and b7 sin initial so the drink one
isn't filling but I want to know can I
prove that these these are equal they
are actually equal so let's compute the
tangent space at a once inserted b1 c1
plus a2 times v2 tensor see - trust me
this is a general point by the secant
variety of this secret this guy C okay
so I applied terry kneisler
this says that I need to take the
standard space is going to be a 1 tensor
you want answers
c1 directsound with am on a 1
okay so that's the first one and then
right so then there are the second one
who in your space I think you see how
this is going
okay so that's the tendon space at this
point and now I want to count dimensions
so I think it's slightly easier to count
just the indices which occur so all
indices are either 1 1 1 or 2 1 1 or 1 2
1 1 2 that's what occurs here
two-dimensional vector spaces these are
the possible indices that could occur
and then these are all indices 2 - 2 - 1
- 2 - 1 - 2 - 1
so just by writing down the indices of
the vectors what you can occur and the
basis it's very clear that these two
having balls this is a having ball at
distance what radius one around like 1 1
1 and this hand ball radius 1 around the
point 2 2 - these two having balls don't
intersect these two tension spaces don't
intersect
so therefore the dimension of this space
is the sum of these dimensions would - 1
because we're working or projectors
there so this is actually just hidden
spaces the c8 and so this means that the
two varieties are equal okay so
the last thing about what to expect and
tests reverberate I think they're going
to have to wait until the next time but
I think you can tell you what to expect
for a number and decompositions and then
all the other time so how many a
composition should you expect forgiven
10 sir how many solutions should you
expect the system of equations
how I figure out the punchline so in
general
we expect that the dimension of Six
Sigma are ta see well I need to choose
our points from this space
and then I need to choose a point on the
our plane which they span that's what I
expect the dimension is supposed to be
so before I say how many them how many I
think I'll actually hold this so next
time let's say they expected rank at the
top center so we expect Sigma R to fill
see when okay let's solve this this is
just one our
this one whenever this exceeds that
times and which is P minus one so then
we take the ratio so we want R to be
bigger than or equal to P divided by
okay so now if somebody asks you what
rank to respect over complex numbers and
the tensor that size n by n by P then
whenever R is larger than this ratio in
it if you should expect well the
smallest r that satisfies that that's
going to be the expected rank now there
are exceptions to this and we don't even
know what all the exceptions are we have
a guess what we think they are but we do
not know all of the exceptions to this
rule and it's a study of an act at an
area of active research and then also
for more than more than three factors
also very interesting with single people
in the audience at work on this problem
and next time I'll start with a
symmetric tensor decomposition and I
will talk about what to expect for
number of decompositions that we'll talk
about algorithms for tensor
decomposition that's right that's why I
never said this is the dimension could
be wrong right
for instance matrices try that example
see whether you get maybe the smallest
example where it fails try this one for
five years
already with three factors there's
something there's so many factors as
well so how about P 2 plus P 2 across 2
and then Sigma 4 this is expected to
fill that it's actually have their
surface Ostrosky is to reunite at their
surface so the expected number you
expect us to be to fill the ambient
space that actually fails to fully under
his face because there's an equation
which vanishes on this variety so I
didn't have time to talk about equations
for a test for the tarentines limit is
still correct but we're so lucky that in
this case the vector is in the tender
space are always given by well in this
case having balls and indices are given
by having balls or the certain radius
radius one centered around the point
that we started with but those timing
balls don't have to fill like just right
they filled in the space they can
overlap right so especially like pigs II
suppose D were one-dimensional instead
of two-dimensional then I would expect
it to be an overlap that's right so I
put plus here as well so in fact this is
the direct sound but maybe I guess you
can understand its feelers is as up
surprisingly that's not a common case so
but if N equals n equals P then dot P to
cross P 2 plus P 2 is the unique time
worked out that was my spot
we've got us a question about the summer
I don't fight across the reservation
they thought the Subspace present so if
we take all their blackness there as we
take the miners over given sign a state
together generate the correct primer
generally so suppose I just take some of
the flat hands and I take a collection
of splits that I like these things may
not be reduce or there are nice examples
where they're reducible as it's been
studied okay so I'm now a member of
yourself with dry summer on baby
and so I think in summary study in
between varieties and those are examples
of the things that you're mentioning
very interesting so suppose I just
so I just picked one direction for the
flat things then I'm just looking at a
variety of matrices of lower rank so
that's your reducible and there's a lot
to learn about those and then maybe I
picked two directions with flat things
instead of just one and I could study
that for Aggie the first place I would
look for a way to solve this problem so
probably be there's this book about sand
the ranked varieties in his book but I
forgot to mention this like subspace
right errr always contains the secant
variety so this is why I brought this up
in there very good game forgot to
mention this time so the first check
whether you have bordering are this
first checked if you're in this subspace
for any as long it's not trivial there
are a lot of interesting questions like
this like there's a very interesting
thing to study and actually write down
all the specific cases if you have a
three by three by three tensor with two
flattening 's equal to these guys but in
general I think that if you ignore one
of the Platinum's
then you're just going to look at sub R
R P for instance this is just conditions
thank G a less than equal to R
so this is irreducible variety mystified
by this equations suppose you have a a
partially symmetric tensor all right how
can you go ahead and look at the the
plottings of this guy you would have to
look at all the floodings you just have
to look at the the flattening x' that
aren't the symmetric parts and then what
can you say about the the variety yeah
so this is anticipating next lecture but
let me just mention the sense to ask is
suppose I have sim DB from lens burgers
lecture yesterday in the computer
science department this is symmetric
tensors so this means that D IJ okay
many indices is equal to D Sigma I Sigma
J Sigma K for all Sigma and the
symmetric like letters then a flattening
is just a map from 70 minus e V star to
some P P and then treated all the vector
space is the same so I'm lifting this
guy inside of some demacia break the
symmetry think about it as a tensor
inside of some D minus e V tensor send
me a V and then write down the matrix
associated to this is sometimes called a
Henkel matrix of Cadillac vikander is
symmetric flattening now if you have a
tensor that has some partial symmetry
you can break the symmetry or not break
the symmetry and write down a partially
symmetric flattening depending on how
you want to split these up so there's
always these kind of inclusions and
our general conclusions and that which
sometimes get more interesting equations
for secant variety experience but this
well I will talk more about this
you you mentioned there so let's look at
this one here this example typical ranks
over all right so in this case Sigma 2 P
1 R 1 R 1 R 2 typical radius and the
picture here is really nice you know
let's imagine this is my you know R 2 by
2 by 2 and the space is cut by a single
hyper surface called hyper determinant
and on this hyper surface so the hyper
determined that you'd like to buy to
hyper determinate the ranks are going to
be 1 2 or 3 and this cuts the space in
half it's roughly enough not quite
enough and then over here you can have
Rank 2 and over here you can have rank 3
and this is real rank and then maybe the
volume of this space is probably like 30
percent of those and senators I don't
remember the percentage that depends on
your distribution right so it also says
as well so if I randomly throw a dart at
two by two mighty real tensors
- and sometimes nobody better drink
three and then very rarely I'll get a
rank one on this on the surface here and
moreover it also explains why you can't
approximate something from rank three as
something of rank two because if I try
to do that I run into this hyper surface
which was cutting my space in half so
approximation problems can be very
tricky because of this sort of behavior
I know didn't think this is analogous to
the way that polynomials and what
variable have difficulties of real roots
they're just kinda hypersurface dividing
into pieces and solutions but you can't
approximate something right - by
something in the rank or a sequence of
Frank you want to take something that
has rank to an approximated with more
terms yeah of course but all right it
just doesn't look like you do that from
the victory well I mean I'm saying rank
exactly - but I could've written it this
and we've done that way rank three so
when I wrote rank I should have written
it has rank less than or equal to this
number I shoulda said it's rank this if
there's not a smaller expression
all right so if Frank said is true this
type of determinate also has an
interpretation of discriminant when this
discriminant is positive or negative
you're going to land in one of these
chambers
good question so you mentioned it
resolved the ideal of subspace varieties
to scheme by the mind of collecting so
so the the minimal free resolution not
just the first messages but the mineral
for resolution of that ideal is given by
a twisted puzzle complex and all of the
details are in yours is booked but you
can write down a certain parcel of a
decent organization by the product or
cross phone varieties and then you can
actually explicitly write out the
representations for every every stage of
the minimal resolution so we have
perfect understand so you can compute
them all by a buffer of a theorem for
instance so what gets really hard though
is that this math question when we start
working with other types of tensors this
problem is very hard so if you look on
the last page to page of jams book
you'll find an example for skew
symmetric tensors where the where the
result is much more difficult than this
case but this case of is triple
cigarette product case or many factors
just no extra symmetry that's fairly
optimistic
questions comments